my films are always personal
nope stands apart from my other films in
that it's a bigger adventure than i've
ever tried to tell from a filmmaking
perspective
by far my most ambitious
it's a bad miracle
they got a word for that
i purposely wrote something without any
regard to
how possible it
all was pictures up
here we go
thankfully the great hoyt of vanhoytema
one of the best cinematographers and the
mastermind behind some of my favorite
films and favorite imagery responded to
the script and the challenges
it was a very exhilarating ride
always creative fun never scared and
always pushing in the scope of what we
could do this is made for a big screen
on imx cameras and we were not shy of
doing very extreme or crazy things with
those cameras
when you're shooting on imax you just
know you're doing something
cinematically special
the image is so overwhelming
it feels like you're there
i wanted immersion a awe and a fear and
a wonder we all had when we were kids
[Music]
you